No,
I've actually always found something to
be very true,
which is most people don't get those
experiences because they never ask.
I've never found anybody that didn't
want to help me.
If I asked him for help,
I always call him up.
I called up,
this will date me,
but I called up Bill Hewlett when I was
12 years old and he lived in Palo Alto,
was number was still on the phone book
and he answered the phone himself.
Yes.
Hi,
I'm Steve Jobs.
I'm 12 years old.
I am a student in high school and I want
to build a frequency counter and I was
wondering if you had any spare parts I
could have and he laughed and he gave me
the spare parts to build this frequency
counter.
Any gave me a job.
That summary,
you look Packard working on the assembly
line,
putting nuts and bolts together on
frequency counters.
He got me a job in a place that
girlfriend and I was in heaven and I've
never found anyone who said no or hung
up the phone when I call.
I just asked.
And when people ask me,
I try to be as responsive.
You have to pay that,
that debt of gratitude back.
Um,
most people never pick up the phone and
call,
and most people never ask.
And that's what separates sometimes the
people to do things from the people that
just dream about them.
Gotta be you gotta Act and you've got to
be willing to fail.
You've got to be willing to crash and
burn,
you know,
with people on the phone with starting a
company with whatever.
If you're afraid of failing,
you won't get very far.